uh dude i but i have a gift
if you just had that [ __ ] book give
me your
[ __ ]
i bought it i bought
and i wanted to surprise you and i i
figured we could read a couple excerpts
i bought the hardcover too this is
yeah and it's also i confirm that it is
indeed a bestseller right now
it is okay it's killing dude okay okay
we're about to just promo his book for
free this isn't promo
no it's not i mean this is book club
we're not gonna be like you guys should
definitely take
no let's read a couple and let's laugh
at them
lads holy [ __ ] this is like a real book
let me see i thought it was only gonna
be
like pictures phrases and little poems
gonna open it it's just
[Music]
pictures of him with like three words
each
that's just basic as hell just like a
little sock on his junk
it's just like i'm hot yeah it's
all it's not even advice this is all
whiskey ads
jesus it's all just direct quotes from
fans
i'd [ __ ] this guy okay here we go here's
one this is this is like a little
post-it note here
bro so there's pages of words words i
know there's like a book club it's a
book
yeah pages of words yeah and then every
so often there's a little image
of a poem he wrote or something on like
a little post-it so i'm gonna read one
of those
i gotta see just just because the seats
are empty
doesn't mean they're not taken sometimes
the guest list needs to be
for one you
bro what give me this let me get one
we're gonna say i know there's a book
club somewhere that's that's like losing
it because you let the cover fly off and
just the way you're handling it like put
him back on the thing yeah i'm not gonna
lie the
the actual that's hard as hell yeah
without the paper that's [ __ ] hard
this design is dope
yeah oh maybe you're supposed to pull
that off i've never had a book before so
i don't know what you do now you are
promoting
yeah i actually am let's read one
oh yeah i'm not gonna lie these like
childhood pictures are like what people
try to capture
and like this is what people want to
look like on instagram you know what i
mean
that's hard yeah during college or
something yeah
wall full of posters and [ __ ] dang dang
what in the [ __ ] this book is it's like
a real book
yeah oh you gotta read this [ __ ] i'm
gonna read it
i have to read it i have to read it just
for us
for the audience and if anyone else has
read it let me know what you think
we should do like a little book club
okay so here are the contents bro
who cares all right so you
so there's like a green light page with
like a title it's like a chapter
part one outlaw logic
dad had just gotten home from work
greasy blue
buttoned down with jim on the left chest
patch
already thrown in the washer this is
this fan fiction
okay man i just want the green light
yeah read another read another like
little excerpt
like a little poem okay i need to find
one of those
how did you find that oh here we go
green line
knowing the truth seeing the truth and
telling the truth
are all different experiences
which is kind of true that's kind of
true
i know you can know something but not
say anything
because you're too scared to say it yeah
you can see the truth pan out
but still you might be afraid to say
something but when you finally say
something how can you see the truth
without knowing that it's the truth
[Applause]
maybe they're non-linear you can see the
truth but not
know it [ __ ] you wanna know some scary
ass [ __ ]
what i didn't send i mean it's not
actually that scary
but it's it's you know some scary-ass
kid no it's kind of it's kind of dope
actually there's a bomb
in this building yeah that's mine that's
my other gift
spice things up a little bit read one
more and then i'll tell you this it's a
conspiracy theory
oh okay i'd like to dive into that i
like that all right
let me try to get another find your
frequency
then one day hit me i lost my truck all
right
holy [ __ ] this is a deep green light
right here what is that you ready
yeah process of elimination and identity
the first step that leads to our
identity in life
is usually not i know who i am but
rather
i know who i'm not process of
elimination
this is all of his [ __ ] poems too
many options can make a tyrant out of
any of us so we should get rid of excess
in our lives that keep us from being
more of ourselves
when we decrease the options that don't
feed us we
eventually almost accidentally
have more options in front of us that do
what this is how he this is how he goes
about writing these he thinks about like
a common trope
yeah or like a you know like a uh what
the [ __ ] is it
okay because it's called grass is
greener on the other side and he goes
it's not about the grass being greener
on the other side it's about how green
can you make the grass
on your side and you're like oh oh
[ __ ] i forgot to fertilize the grass
yeah yeah
knowing who we are is hard how it's
about how much grass can you smoke
on your side eliminate who we're not
first then we'll find ourselves where we
need to be
i guess i that's kind of true yeah sort
of
but that just means you have to try
everything bro this is do
everything this is when you realize who
you're not this is like [ __ ] that you
like
nothing i was gonna say something shitty
it's fine what that's fine
let's just say it that's just man i
don't know
this this to me is just like you know
this is like hot people [ __ ]
you know i mean like how people could
like say this [ __ ] and like welcome back
to the intel hour yeah
yeah no it's not even that it's like i'm
not even about to say like
you know oh they don't do it or whatever
i just mean
you know i feel like it's stuff
that hot people could say and like a
broken person will be like oh my god
like you're like the answer to my uh
you know what i mean yeah it's really to
get you
to like him more and not help yourself
yeah i would say like if we yeah
i'm just trying to i'm imagining myself
saying that [ __ ] to somebody and getting
the door slammed on me
you know like socially or something if
i'm like
you know knowing who we are is hard yeah
that's great um
do you want to go back to the group
oh yeah i was just going to tell you
know usually
figuring out who we are you know it's
it's a matter of the options around us
yeah yeah it totally yeah totally i get
that
i get that we should go back to the
group yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah no for sure yeah [ __ ] me
i don't know
two agnostics oh oh oh
that means you don't believe in god
right yes
no no agnostic is like you don't you
don't
you don't you don't subscribe to like a
religion yeah yeah but you're not um
you're not atheist yeah you're just you
know you're open to the idea
okay to agnostics just because it says
anonymous
doesn't mean it has no author
i don't that makes me want to be a
scientologist
that's what this is about
ron hubbard is my dude
that's just page one
arm now ron hubbard is my guy
you funded this whole book and i'm here
to show you the green light
into scientology oh lord here's one
oh this is a good one holy [ __ ] let it
rip
this is this is also some landscape this
[ __ ] this is perfect okay this works
perfectly with what we're talking about
this is a manscaped reed in the middle
of the book
[Laughter]
twizzle your taint with the taint
twizzler with the twist twist twist
twist
with the tank twist test taste and tie
with your twist test
taint twizzler some people want the ac
on in the gym so they won't sweat ah
i wear my beanie in july so i will
holy [ __ ] that's it that's it that's
literally
that's so good
some people look for an excuse to do
others look for an excuse
not to these are bars dude
we actually we should make a song that's
just all these oh yeah
we just rip them wholesale it's called
green light
green light that's a that's actually a
very a very
dangerous title to go with
green light green light is like like i
put the green light on you like
get you [ __ ] murdered yeah what about
this
in a green light okay
okay john legend or something yeah yeah
where do you go
right now yeah but you know
if we all made sense of humor the
default emotion
we'd all get along better oh my god
that's like
some five-year-old [ __ ] right there
laugh more
but this is memoir dude so you know each
each one of these
is probably you know rolled up in some
story ah man this is [ __ ] awesome
i'm definitely going to read this are
you
maybe i'll read it maybe we'll do a book
club i mean like book club for the
[ __ ]
we should actually do that and just like
discuss it in depth like seriously what
we think
you